what are you
reading the dance of jackets what's it
about it's the story of the fight
between rera Targaryen and her half by
the rean for control of the Seven
Kingdoms both of them thought they
belonged on the Iron Throne when people
started declaring for one of them or the
other their fight divided the kingdoms
in Two Brothers fought Brothers dragons
fought
Dragons by the time it was over
thousands were dead
and it was a disaster for the targaryan
as well they never truly
recovered DS of
dragons why is it
dance it's just what they call it make
sense I think it's
poetic if you'd had to
choose between reir and
P who would you have chosen I wouldn't
have chosen either
saw the choosing sides to made
everything so horrible sometimes a
person has to
[Music]
choose for free you can now listen to
the entire audio book Fire and Blood On
which house of the Dragon is based and
which covers the entire Targaryen
history including current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
with a notable trial using our Link in
the description I